- C'est un coin rarement visité
de la campagne ukrainien..
Une région caractérisée par
la richesse de ses pâturages,
et la pauvreté de sa ptititititc
un État fantoche, soutenu par
la Russie, la répuiqique
auto-proclamée de Transnistrie.
(souffle du vent)Une frontière e
souvient qu'il la traversait
auparavant plusieurs fois par
vivaient de part et d'autre sans
problème. Mais la guerre avec
la Russie a tout compliqué.
"On ne peut plus passer, dit
soldats armés." p p p p p p p pt
plus voir sa femme ni son fils.
de nouvelles de ses enfants,
coincés de l'autre côté de
la frontière, depuis des mois.
Alors, elle a choisi de ne plus
regarder la télé pour éviter de
trop s'inquiéter.
"C'est difficile et je pleure
parfois, avoue-t-elle. Bien
T T T Tous retraités, Aleksandt
ses voisins se soutiennent, et
s'entraident mutuellement.
la situation qu'ils ne trouvent,
franchement, pas rassurante.
(bruits de moteur)
Viktor o o o o o ne le cache
pas, tous ici, craignent que
la Russie décide d'attaquer
l'Ukstststststststststststststs.
"Nous avons tous peur que
la guerre vienne ici, dit-il.
Bien sûr que nous avons peur."
(jappements)
Ce qui inquiète sdedededededede
qui radicalise les opinions.
rlrlrlrlrlrlrlrlrlrlrlrlrlrlrlrt
d'actes terroristes dans
les médias, AlAlAlAlAlors
bien sûr, ça influence ce que
les gens pensent là-bas."
Nostalgiques d'une époque où
tous mangeaient à la même table
comme des frères, partageant
un même morceau de pain,
et d'un retour de la raison.
Mais ils s'avouent pessimistes
et se sentent impuissants.
Pour les gens ici, le conflit
qui se a a a a a a a a a a a a s
paru comme quelque chose de
loesesesesesesque abstrait.uiui,
la guerre est bien plusèèèèèète.
Et dans ce contexte, l
d'un kilomètre d'ici, en
Transnistrie, ap
beaucoup plus menaçants.
Ici Jean-François Bélanger,
Radio-Canada,